(Indian music)
- For me, he was a guru.
He was a teacher who's
gonna make me perfect.
So I told my family that I have to go
to US teacher training.
I was like biggest decision
for me to leave my child
with my mom because he was very small.
But I want to just do something to make me
stand on my feet.
Like, okay, let's do this Mandeep.
Let's do this.
(somber music)
- Turn the lights up,
open the door please.
- [Mandeep] Bikhram was
teaching the class at that time.
- All lights.
All down.
So he saw me, ask that girl
is she know how to do massage?
And only one answer
"Yes, of course I know"
After one or two days,
one of the teachers said
"Bikram is calling you"
Like, "Okay, what time?"
"Now"
"Now? It's 2 o'clock in the night"
I entered into the suite room
I just said the greeting, like
"Hello sir"
And he's like, "yeah,
yeah, come, come, come"
And then he went to the
room, his personal room,
so he was lying down on the floor.
And, "You're going to take this oil
"and, you know, massage"
Like, okay, fine.
And I was just massaging the shoulders,
combing his hair
massaging his hands.
And he talk a lot.
I have to just listen.
And then he like, "Nobody's
here to handle my empire.
"I have done so much for everybody.
"Nobody's taking care of me.
"Not even my family."
Okay.
And he was just telling me now
"Do it from here,
alright, do it from here."
Then slowly, slowly he's guiding me.
"Do it here, do it here"
and go to, you know, like the main.
Like, "Okay, now, put your
hand on my inner thighs
"and do it"
And he actually said, 'Okay,
okay, massage my dick."
I was like
blind.
He grabbed my hand and
tried to put it there,
and then I said
"I can't do this.
"You're my guru.
"I have different
"what do you say?
"Image.
"You know different image as a guru.
"So, I'm sorry I can't do that."
- Your hips like this.
Not like this.
(Mandeep speaking drowns
out Bikram's teaching)
- What he's gonna do next now
with me?
He came, "What happened, why do you want
to leave the teacher training?"
Like, "You know what happened."
"Nothing happened, Mandeep!"
"For you, maybe not.
"But for me, yes.
"I can't take this."
Like, "Okay.
"Don't worry, it's not
going to happen again.
"You continue your teacher training."
- Bikram was very, very,
very good at knowing
when to turn the whole crowd.
So he'd be your best friend in one second,
and the next minute, he's
like screaming insanely
at someone.
I mean, can I swear?
- [Interviewer] Yes, you still can.
- Like, "You fucking bitch"
- Take a deep breathe.
Now drop your hip back.
Now drop back!
In half a second!
Go 'head,
Up back, touch the wall!
Touch the wall!
Touch the fucking wall!
Now go down, go down,
go down, go down, go down.
How's he gonna reach now?
Bitch.
(students laughing)
Don't you understand English?
How will you get down?
Chicken shit.
Now go down.
- So I'm seeing this with my own eyes,
but you don't imagine
that you're seeing it.
When you think about these people
are like, starving.
And they're sleep-deprived.
And this yoga just wipes you out.
You're ripe for whatever
wants to be entered in next.
- Remets nine weeks.
The students are living in the hotel.
That's basically their
dorm for nine weeks.
They're doing all their classes and
all their lectures in the hotel.
They're not allowed to leave.
And Bikram, although he
has a home in Los Angeles,
lives in the hotel, in
the Presidential Suite.
It was disturbing for me to discover
that there was this tendency to watch
Bollywood movies very late at night
in Bikram's bedroom.
- I came back.
Over and over again.
Expecting different results,
and I know that's the
definition of being an idiot.
We were all supposed to
stay up late with Bikram.
He never slept.
We'd get a call sometimes
at three in the morning,
"Where are you? Come to my room.
"I need company, I'm lonely."
So, we were watching a movie
and he asked me to come sit with him.
I just started massaging his hand.
(characters in the movie speaking)
And then I laid my head
on the side of the couch.
And fell asleep.
(movie music)
One of the other senior
staffers woke me up.
And he said, you know the movie's over
and we're leaving.
And I got up
and I realized I didn't have my shoes on
and I had my bag, also.
And so I went to go look for my shoes
and look for my bag that
I'd set down earlier
in the night somewhere in his huge suite.
Out in the living room.
He said, "We're leaving now, let's go"
I said "Just a minute, I
have to find my shoes."
And I heard the door click.
And they'd left.
And I hurried to the door
and Bikram was already there.
And I went to open it, and
he pushed himself up into me.
And he only had his underwear on.
And I could feel him.
I kept trying to push
down the door handle,
but the door opened in
and he had his pressure against the door,
and my body was up against the door.
And he started kissing all over my neck
and all down my chest.
And he was pushing himself into me.
And
he just kept saying, "I'm
gonna have you this time"
I thought, "He's going to rape me."
And I was able to use my
elbow to move him off,
and I slipped under him and I slipped out.
And I remember as I left, I
said goodnight to him, even.
I said, "Goodnight, boss".
(soft music)